robbing all these spatial separations
between shallow ponds to the classical
circuits thanks for the introduction
thanks for having me here I'm gonna be
talking about exponential separations
between shallow quantum circuits and
shallow classical circuits and this is
joint work with Adam Benny Watts Luke
Shaefer and avishay tell you motivate
the setting we're looking for provable
separations in power between quantum and
classical computers so that's that's the
that's the big picture idea so we want
examples of problems that there's an
exponential gap between quantum in
classical and that you can prove this so
for example things like factoring we do
believe that factoring can be solved in
polynomial time on quantum computers and
that may be we know we believe that it
can't be solved in polynomial time on
classical computers but we can't prove
that and because it would be a huge
breakthrough in complexity and if you
could prove something like that so if
you want to focus on provable statements
approvable separations you could do some
stuff in query complexity for example or
communication complexity these are other
avenues you can prove something but the
the context of this talk is we're going
to talk about circuits and specifically
about constant DEP circuits so this is a
model of computation where we can
actually prove unconditional results and
that's one of the motivations why we
study constant depth or shallow circuits
the other motivation might be just that
shallow
coño circuits might be implementable in
on near-term or medium-term quantum
computers in the future so I give some
practical motivation for looking at
shallow classical circuits so the
players in this game are constant depth
circuit classes and if you haven't seen
these before let me let me introduce
them to you let me start with the
classical shallow circuits class that's
called NC zero so some of you might know
what this is it's it's constant depth so
what constant depth means the depth does
not depend on the input size so that's
what constant means polynomial size so
everything we're going to talk about
today is polynomial size circuits
classical circuits
and and the gate set is important and
and the gate set is you just have these
gates as you have and gates which taken
two inputs and output one bit or gates
which taken one two bits every one bit
and and negation gates we turns out that
for NC zero it's not really relevant
what the gate said is any reasonable
constant rise gates like we're doing but
conventionally this is this is the set
of gates that we assume yeah so this is
NC 0 set of all classical circuits of
constant depth polynomial size use these
kind of gates and just give an example
your input bits are x1 to xn and you
have some some gates like this or gates
and gates there's more of them whatever
I think and you might have multiple
output wires which I might call y1 y2 y3
whatever ym so throughout this talk I'm
gonna assume that our circuits have n
inputs and multiple outputs so it's not
just computing boolean functions of one
output but there's many output bits this
is the first player that we gonna be
introduced to and c0 you can feel free
to ask questions at any point okay no
questions so far the the other player
I'll introduce it here AC 0 is very
similar to NC 0 except the gate set is
different from the gate set so all of
this is the same but the gate set is
same gates but now they can have
unbounded fan in which means they can
take in as many inputs as they want and
it's it's kind of clear how the end and
or gates would generalize to unbounded
fan in so if you if you don't know what
these functions are the end function is
where the output is 1 if and only if all
of its input bits are 1 the or function
is 1 if and only if any of its input
bits is 1
this is a c0 constant death polynomial
sighs classical circuits where you have
unbounded fanon and in or gates
everyone's on board so far these are the
only two classical complexity classes
that you need to know about for this
talk and finally we're going to talk
about the quantum analog of of this
class over here which I'm gonna call
quantum NC 0 so this is as the name
suggests a quantum this thing so the
only thing here that you'd have to
generalize a constant that polynomial
size all that stuff is the same the
thing if it generalizes the gate set and
for concreteness I'm just gonna
something quantum everything else is I
stays the same and for concreteness I'm
gonna take the gate set of Hadamard you
see nah I don't know just yeah choose
your favorite gates I guess doesn't
matter let's say let's throw something
else in let's go and face whatever just
show some complete gate set or
clifford's plus T maybe maybe that's
more convenient it's it it doesn't
matter
some gate set of 2 cubed gates some
discrete side I really like something
that I was like let's say size 5 or 6
capes and essentially the same
definition and maybe let me just draw a
little picture just to give you some
intuition for what this might look like
now your inputs are qubits and then you
have some gates possibly two qubit gates
and one qubit gates and so on and at the
end of the day you might have output
bits y1 to yn
that's what I'm gonna call a constant
depth quantum circuit or qnz zero that's
right yeah so I'm also gonna allow
polynomial number of insula bits so I
guess you could you could get more yeah
but it doesn't actually matter it seems
like you generally always need linear
number of no so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna look at circuits solving problems
so the initial set is gonna be in the
input to the problem so more precisely
I'm gonna look at relation problems or
search problems and what these problems
are is you have some set of inputs or
maybe let me step back a bit before
relational search problems the normal
thing we usually look at this function
computation problems were you have some
input and the input uniquely corresponds
to want output like it's a function in
the usual sense of the word function so
you have some this is let's say this is
the input domain and this is the output
domain you have some input here and they
put get map gets mapped to one guy over
here a relation problem is where each
input may have many outputs so that's
what a relationship relation problem is
and we'd only going to talk about
relationship problems right now and it
turns out this is essential because if
you look at function computation
problems qn c 0 & NC 0 turn out to have
the same power so it's not very
interesting
so if relation problem what's gonna
happen is the input x1 to xn is going to
be this some input here and the output
will be the thing you output over there
and maybe the thing I should mention
which is which spurred all of this work
it's a very nice result of bravia
Gossett and Koenig from 2018 which
showed that there is a relation problem
let me just call it our that can be
solved by a constant of quantum circuit
qnc zero but R is not in NC zero so you
solve it at the quantum circuit of
constant depth but you cannot solve the
classical circular concept
so we've taken two models of computation
there are analogs of each other so it's
like an apples to apples comparison and
we've shown that the quantum model is
more powerful unconditionally no
assumptions or rather robbie gossett can
ensure this so that's great this is the
kind of thing we like doing in quantum
computing or ensuring showing separation
doing quantum and classical models so
this was Robbie Gossett counting 80 and
the work and you can tell you about
today is a strengthening of this work a
follow up this work so our work so what
we do is we extend the lower bound
further to a more powerful classical
model so way to AC zero circuits AC zero
circuits extremely well studied in
classical complexity theory in fact have
been since like the early 80s super
interesting model of computation you can
save a lot of things about it we
understand it very well and they're also
a reasonably powerful model of
computation in fact they can do many
surprising things that you wouldn't
expect that AC zero circuits can do like
they can add numbers and so on and you
might think that to add to n bit numbers
you would need depths that depends on
the number but in fact it doesn't also
ACC can do some trivial things like
computing the end of all n bits all in
input bits obviously because like that's
just a gate but NC 0 can't do that so NC
it was a very weak class whereas AC 0 is
a reasonable powerful class so that's
that was one of the motivations of our
work is just extend this lower bound to
AC 0 circuits and our first result is
just that this this problem is not in AC
0
and this is what I'll say a little bit
about today but we have some strength
things of this as well so in fact we can
show this problem is not even a zero
with essentially with sub-exponential
sized circuits are you close to
exponential size circuits so not only
can polynomial size console dev circuits
not solve this but not even exponential
stress circuits can't do it and the
technical statement something like the
if it has depth D then it's not an AC
zero with size exponential in n to the 1
over 10 D something like this so if you
fix a depth let's say depth 10 then even
an AC 0 circuit of size exponential in n
to the 0.01 can't solve this problem and
then we further extend this to an
average case lower bound which means
that we show that essentially if you
pick a random input and the probability
that a is any AC 0 circuit can solve
this is also exponentially small so
notice that you can always solve any
problem on like let's say one input or
there's two to the N possible inputs you
can always solve any problem on one
input but just having a circuit that
hard codes the answer to that one input
so saying that you can't you can only
solve it in an exponentially small
fraction of inputs is a very strong
statement that's kind of the best you
can hope for so we can also prove that I
won't actually came to that so maybe I
want to write that here okay so that's
the statement of the result any
questions about that
well happy with this ok so I want to
tell you a little bit about the problem
that's used in this work I think the
problem is kind of cute and it's easy to
understand and it's also you it's easy
to see how we came upon the problem
rather I'm gonna tell you the story of
how we found this problem which is also
one of the motivations of this work
really the problem using the original
separation is it's more complicated at
least in my opinion and it's a little
harder to see why why that problem was
chosen present our work I think the
problem is really is I hope you can miss
you that's the case
no question so far that is not good so
the problem is is it's not exactly the
following but it's going to be a small
variation of the following problem and
this problem is what we call the parity
having problem and it has been studied
before under various names like the end
party mermen game and it's a it's
actually a generalization of the GHC
problem but let me just call with this
because you'll see why
so the parity having problem P sub n you
have some input which is an N bit string
with the promise that the Hamming weight
of X is 0 mod 2 so the number of ones
and X is even that's the promise and
your output so recall this is not a
function computation problem there's not
a unique out but there's many valid
outputs so your output is just any there
should be n so there's the input is of
size n and your output is any any string
of length n such that now there's a
condition on Y and the condition let me
write it out explicitly it's it's just
as a as a formula the function is just
that Y should be congruent to X / - what
- but let me let me spit this out what
this means is if so X is a string whose
Hamming weight is even right so if
you're an even number there's two
possibilities here either 0 mod 4 or 2
mod 4 so if x is 0 mod 4 too much for
these are the only two possibilities we
want in this case your output should be
0 mod 2 and in this case that should be
one more - so your task as the person
solving the problem is to accept an
input string whose Hamming weight is
even and then output an input string an
output a string who is which is which is
even if the input string parity was the
Hamming weight as it was by 4 and odd if
it was divisible by not divisible by 4
and it was too much for that's that's
the problem starting with is that good
the problem X make sense everyone
and it turns out that this problem is
actually pretty straightforward to solve
with the qnc zero circuit if you allow
me to start with a cat state so for
those of you don't know what a cat state
is this is what I'm gonna call the cat
States a cat on and qubits is just this
state all zeros plus all ones
so if the qnc zero circuit in addition
to its actual input is also allowed to
start with a cat state like this just
like falls out of the sky you know it's
not it's not being prepared by our
constant depth circuit we just have it
as a resource then it's actually really
easy to solve this problem and this is
just a generalization of the three
player GHC game if you've seen this
before and the idea is just you have n
qubits in the cat state and you have
your n input qubits the x1 to xn each of
them is going to apply a controlled
phase gate on the on its corresponding
qubit in the cat state so the first
input qubit is gonna apply control phase
gate on the first qubit of the cat stay
the second on the second third on the
third and so on so this can be done in
parallel so it's gonna be a depth one
circuit and what that's gonna do is
every time your input bit is one it's
gonna add a I over here that's what a
controlled phase would do and because
there's well there's gonna be a bunch of
X's that are one in fact how many X's
are gonna be one exactly the Hamming
weight of X the state you're gonna get
is 0 to the N plus I to the Hamming
weight of X to the n naught now very
surprising this is a depth one circuit
so far and we know that X is or Hamming
weight of X is even right that was part
of our condition so in fact this splits
up nicely in these two cases if x is 0
mod 4 then here you get back the cat
state
because yeah this is for Aitu the four
is one and in the other in the other
case you get Z to the N minus 1 to the N
so your quantum circuit has prepared one
of two states depending on the two cases
they were trying to distinguish in the
input so that's great we've already in
some sense distinguished the two cases
were trying to distinguish except these
are some quantum states what do you do
with them the first thing you observe is
that they were orthogonal take the inner
product of 0 so this is great this means
we are outputting two orthogonal States
but we had some other condition that we
were supposed to output a string of
length N and it so turns out if you just
apply the hedemark gate to this on all n
qubits Hadamard anything here you will
get exactly a uniform superposition over
strings that satisfy this criteria so
over here if you apply the hedemora
superposition you will get all all
strings whose Hamming weight is even and
to this state if you apply the Hadamard
gate n Hadamard gates you'll get a
superposition over all strings whose
Hamming weight is odd and so that's it
that's the circuit and then you measure
it out with this and now your cue nc0
circuit with a cat state has solved this
problem every one so this we we say in
our paper that PHP n is contained in qnc
zero except it's not contained in Q&C
zero because it needs this cat state so
the complexity theorists will often use
this notation to mean that the circuit
class is given some extra advice state
some state that doesn't depend on the
input just like the cat's tail the cat
say there's no relationship with the
input X or is just some advice it's some
extra resource of the circus given and
we say Q + 0 / cat or in the paper
actually we write Q + 0 / and then
there's a picture of a cat which is kind
of hard to do on the on the board or
something like this so this is a
complexity class that it's in okay so in
there okay any questions about this so
far it's pretty straightforward and the
cool thing is it's in the quantum class
and the the cool but also difficult to
prove somewhat difficult to prove is
that this problem is not in AC 0 so
that's the that's the it's up to the
difficult part of this paper it's
proving that it's not an AC 0 and in
fact proving that it's not only it's not
an AC 0 even if you allow me exponential
size like size n to the 1 over 10 D and
even if I only have to succeed on an
exponential
a small fraction of the inputs which we
see even if I only have to succeed on a
1 over X pen to the 1 over attendee
fraction of the inputs and maybe I'll
say a sentence or two about this but I
want to explain to you how we get rid of
this cat state because this is so far
this is not a solution to the problem we
we're seeking air and I guess most of
you are probably more interested in the
quantum part so I'll focus most of the
time on that well a few things about how
we prove this and the way we prove this
is in three steps so we start with
proving something weaker so you want to
prove it's not an AC 0 what's the weaker
thing you can prove you can prove it's
not an NC 0 sure so that's the weaker
statement but what's actually even
weaker than proving something is not an
NCC dose an NC 0 recall that any output
bit can depend on some constant number
of input bits because the fanon is
bounded so every gate can involve two
two more things and like as you go down
2 ft you can involve say 2 to the D
things it's so constant but you can
depend on a bunch of things and even
weaker model would be if y1 could only
depend on x1 and y2 could only depend on
X - like this is a kind of silly model
but this is actually been studied this
is an end parte communication game where
you give any inputs to n different
players and you ask them to output some
n bit string that satisfies a certain
constraint this is the there's just an N
part a generalization of the GHz game if
you've seen this before and it's not so
hard to prove that the classical players
cannot win the GHC game and or they can
only win in a probability 1/2 plus
exponentially small whereas quantum
players can go to win it with
probability 1 if they start out by
sharing a cat's day this is an old
result so that was already known so that
gives us the claim that this this
problem cannot be solved by a very
special nc0 circuit where every input
only dependents every are only depends
on one input then we go from there to NC
0 circuits essentially by saying that
there's not too many gates and every
output can only depend on a couple of
input variables a constant number of
them so we can essentially just
partition the output into some order n
number of blocks so that each of those
output bits only depends on independent
inputs and this kind of takes us back to
the communication complexity game we
kind of just give all of those
independent push to player one and the
next set of independent inputs a player
two and so on so we can reduce back to
this communication complexity setting
which is already known and that gives us
this NC 0 lower bound and finally to go
from AC 0 to NC 0
this is a some more heavy machinery from
a c0 circuit lower balance we use
switching llama which is a common
technique for proving AC circuit lower
bonds except the off-the-shelf lemmas
don't work as well because we're really
dealing with function problems I mean
relation problems and not single output
problems and many traditional AC 0
circular burn techniques only consider
the case where there's only one output
variable and we have to use the fact
that there's many output variables so
anyway there's some work here but let me
not talk about that let me get to how do
we fix this issue of getting rid of the
cat's day so one thing to note maybe
it's not totally obvious but the cat
state cannot be created in qnc zero you
just need a log depth to create this cat
state so there's no solution that's
gonna be like oh here's a slick
algorithm for creating the cat state
that's not gonna happen
so what do we do and yeah what we do is
we can create something that's kind of
like the cat state it's something what
we call the the poor man's cat state and
this can be done in q NC 0 let me just
explain it with an example so let's see
if sign of that started with a line of
qubits in the plus state and for each of
these qubits you you measure the parody
of adjacent qubits so you you measure
whether these two qubits are equal or
not so or is it this is in the state 0 0
or 1 1 or or not and I'm gonna call this
bit d1 so you perform an actual
measurement that distinguishes the case
where they are the same or they're
different
let me call this DN minus 1 these are
some classical bits this is these are
the measurement outcomes so let's say
you got the measurement outcome where
all the DS are equal to 0 so you've got
D 1 equal to 0 D 2 equal to 0 and so on
what does that mean about the resulting
state over here what that means is that
this qubit value is equal to this
keepers value is equal to this keep its
value and so on
if all the parity is zero and the only
two states that have that property or 0
to the N and 1 to the N and if you work
it out you'll see that if you do get the
all 0 string you in fact have create
created the cat State and this is a
constant depth circuit right you started
with all pluses that's a depth 1 circuit
and then you just measure all of these
guys that can all be done in parallel or
maybe not technically in parallel
because these two guys are touching the
same qubit but you can do them in Tula
it's a constant DEP circuit and you
created the cat state right so that's
that's great what's what's the problem
right right what do I mean by
conditioning right exactly so the
probability that these are all 0 is
extremely unlikely it's exponentially
unlikely so so that's not good so the
other so instead what you can ask
yourself is what happens in general for
some arbitrary set of D 1 to the N minus
1 now what happens is you get some
superposition like this some n bit
strings Z plus Z complement divided by
root 2 so in this case it was all zeros
but this is just some string and it's
complement divided by root 2 and we call
this guy this the state over here that
the poor man's cat state because it's
kind of like a cat's day but but it's
not okay and so yeah so how do we fix
the problem so and this this state is
created in Q + C 0 as I described it's
just that this Z is not in your control
it's a completely random string z and z
bar but you can you can derive the value
of Z because you have these these
measurement outcomes so you can figure
out what Z is from these things right
because there's only two strings that
will satisfy this there's there's n
variables like Z 1 to Z N and there's n
minus 1 constraints given by this parity
constraint so there's 2 strings and you
can figure them out it's something like
if you there's two possibilities for
this guy this guy can be 0 or 1 but once
you fix this guy let's say 0 then this
has to be D 1 this 1 has to be D 1 X
already - this one has to be 1 X or so
once you have the DS you can figure out
what C and Z Z bar are
yeah that's very complicated so I'm just
saying in principle you can figure it
out you certainly cannot figure it out
in constant depth because you're
computing parodies of very long strings
but the DS encode disease in a
complicated way okay so we have this
poor man's cascade that we can prepare
in constant depth we have this parody
having problem which needs a cat state
to solve it so what are we gonna do
we're gonna do this classic life gives
you lemons make lemonade strategy which
is just use this state instead and see
what happens right you you'll get some
quantum circuit so the quantum circuit
has just created this poor man's cat
state and then just run the circuit
assuming it was a cat state and
something happens the quantum circuit
will do something and that's the
computational problem so that's it so
just just go with you know what happened
like you're like okay I couldn't do it
well you know I'll just take the closest
thing I can do plug that in you'll get
some computational problem what is the
problem you get I can say what it is
it's it's actually not very complicated
it's just here you get an extra term you
get a plus X inner product Z that's
what's gonna happen like the the output
will satisfy the following condition
that this the Hamming weight of the
output string Y will be X divided two
plus the inner part of X and the X and z
are both n bit strings so this inner
product is just some over IX i zi okay
so that's something the other thing that
you can also output is you have these
bits lying around so you also output
those because otherwise Z is not defined
like if you the input is X you output
some string Y and it has to only satisfy
this equation for any Z you choose then
you can just choose you to be these you
know this is always satisfied for some Z
so you have to somehow output Z except
you don't know how to output Z because
you don't have Z you just have this cats
this poor man's cat state we're just
going to get destroyed by you're out of
them but you have this string which
encodes Z's so the new problem is going
to have two outputs now which is not
just Y what's going to have Y and the
string D you measured and the new output
criterion is this one and that's that's
our problem so that's a problem that is
now in Q NC 0 without this cat state by
construction like that's how we came up
with the problem
it's and it's also not in Macy's you
know this this takes a little bit of
work to prove and actually I glossed
over one detail which is that this poor
man's cat state there's actually many
different ways to create it like this
was just one idea that you take a line
and measure all the neighboring qubits
but the other thing you can do is you
could take a drill and put qubits on the
grid and do the same thing just make all
the measurement measurements of all the
pairs of all the all the neighbors and
you'll again get some string of parodies
D 1 D 2 and so on
again if all of them are 0 then this is
the cat state if they're not 0 then
there's something it turns out this is
the one that we actually need to use
this construction doesn't work right
that's just a minor detail it's the same
story essentially we we were able to
make some kind of cat state which was
not really the cat said we wanted but we
just plugged it in we've got a problem
and it remained hard and we really prove
it by reduction so this this new problem
the one way we have this poor men's cats
it we call it the relaxed parity having
problem and we show this is not an AC 0
but it's actually an implication this
way so well all the work we did in
proving this was not an ACC was actually
useful it just it follows from that that
this problem is done the AC 0 and in
fact all the lower bounds we show like
in fact all the size depth trade-offs
etcetera that exponential size AC 0
circuits cannot solve the problem and
exponential on explanation what fraction
of the inputs whatever we prove about
this original problem we can just get it
directly for this problem so in from the
perspective of AC 0 these problems are
basically the same like the hardness is
the same except from the perspective of
qnc 0 they're completely different
because this problem can be solved by Q
and C circuits the other one could not
have or we yeah we don't have cat States
in Q n Caesars we couldn't solve it yeah
so that's the story of this problem that
proves this result and maybe the final
thing I just wanted to say about the
problem is that our problem also
technically reduces to the problem
that's used in the original result of
Brava Casa de Kooning so we also showed
that their problem is not an AC 0 if you
specifically care about their problem
their problem is harder has more
structure so maybe we yeah we also just
can straight forward implication all the
implications go through everything about
AC circuits of exponential size etcetera
yeah so that that's basically all I
wanted to say we just want to give you
an example explanation of what the
problem was and how we came the story of
how we came up with the problem and it's
totally intuitive and these proofs are
not super hard maybe the only hard part
is the switching lemma which in our
paper is completely black box so you can
just use the switching lemma as a black
box you don't have to yes yes so
actually every time I use the classical
circuit class you can put something like
slash randomized polynomial size advice
so as in they they're allowed to start
with random probable polynomial sized
probability distribution of their choice
that can be arbitrarily complicated it
could be even very hard to sample from
for everything even the AC zero circuit
the AC circuit of exponential size can
even start out with an exponentially
complicated probability specifying yes
everything holds against this yeah so
the way we flip phrase it in the paper
actually is we just rephrase it as a
distribution of lower bound so we give a
hard input distribution so then you can
actually get rid of the probability that
AC circuit so so it does hold for that
side
okay so in the classical setting a c0 is
extremely sensitive with choice of gate
search if you don't use and and or and
if you something else and instead of
ending our use like I say the parity
gate or something then this problem is
actually very easily solvable because
you would just compute the parity of X
and you would figure out which are the
two cases you're in so the complexity
class a c0 is very sensitive to get such
so and it's and it is important that
it's and in or we also have a partial
result here that we can extend this all
of this stuff I mean most of the stuff
to a c0 with mod to gates
except we would only able to go to the
point where we have a problem that needs
a cat state we're not able to get rid of
the cat state like here so this class is
very sensitive the gate set this one is
not doesn't matter any constant size
gates that is fine
and for the quantum class in some sense
it is sensory it's a because you need to
be able to do these operations like the
things I did over here this is a control
phase gate and this was a Hydra Mart
so you need these two gates so if you
have some gate set that cannot produce
these two gates with a constant number
of gates and I mean it might be that you
might need a lot many gates if you use
this Oliver khatai of similar to the
decomposition then it won't be a
constant of circuit anymore so it is
somewhat sensitive everything it said
but it's a very very mild requirement
all you need is controlled phase and had
emerged we take one more question a it
may be computing my columns like go HM
go is John was Ronnie where the idea is
to like no matter how can try the
problem is like can we just drew some
separation is there any way to push this
to some problem that's
yeah yeah so I think the the original
work of bravi Gosselin Koenig maybe is a
little bit in that direction except that
problem is also somewhat I try it
depends on a perspective it something
like there's a matrix and there's it
defined some quadratic for me if you
differently talked about its kernel over
some yeah we're something some field and
then you have to output some vector
that's orthogonal to something because
the kernel has a linear structure that's
also somewhat contrived but you might
say maybe that's more linear algebraic
but there is hope of going in that
direction because that problem is
somehow inherently about linear algebra
and there's hope that you could make it
talked about like some regular problem
that regular people know about rather
than this very contrived problem our
Virginia is just extremely contrived I
guess and that's in that sense but that
was actually part of the motivation for
this work and that's actually what makes
this lower bound result go through as
well that our problem is input symmetric
we couldn't apply our techniques to
their problem or we failed at doing it
because their problem has a lot of
structure in the input whereas here it
doesn't matter it's just all the power
of the Hamming weight and this was key
to making a lower bounds work okay
[Applause]